So obviously it's best for all of us if this goes as smoothly as possible. Less stress, that's the operative word here.
I've said that you can't just pop by--Just five minutes
Can I borrow your warm hat?
You said hey to Auntie Beth?
My son, my sister, and her husband took care of him while I was in prison and now they won't share custody.
It's not my clients, who are going to hear the word manslaughter attached to their name.
I was released on good behaviour a year ago.
I gave you my phone number.
Why? -Well argued.
What's with the ten year gap in the employment history?
I really need this job, i'm trying to get my son back.
It's really messed up, I'd be surprised if she ever sees that kid again.
This girl I was representing didn't fit the picture of what a good person is supposed to look like.
Neither do you.
Do you want to get a drink?
Pretty much all I do is drink with strangers, so... you'll do.
It's like a different kind of nightmare.
There's a monster out there and I can't see it and I can't fight it.
See, what they're trying to do is trying to beat you.
What is up with you?
Come over here and say that to me again!
It's understandable.
It's not understandable they won't let me see my son.
Well, no, I didn't--
Don't ever touch me again, okay?
Where does this go, in your mind, when you were planning this whole thing out, where is the best place that this goes?
My spirit has had too many tests, I don't think it can take anymore.
This is the part where you say, "Yes, your honor."
Shut up-shut up!
Bad things happen to people who don't deserve it everyday and it's going to happen over and over again.
I just need one person to take a chance on me.